[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen um
thank you all for attending this evening
um of tonight's meeting of external
overview and scrutiny we have a small
hitch our guest speaker is not here yet
we're meant to be having a presentation
from the link
um this evening
which we have arranged um that the
ladies not here so we'll give her a few
moments we'll just go through
other bits and pieces
i'm sure we will fill our time
okay apologies for absence
chair we have apologies from cats
thank you karen and minutes of the last
meeting
i'll go through page by page
and
[Music]
i'll read the page number at the bottom
number three it starts on
[Music]
page four
page five
page six
um
thank you
thank you
page seven
and then page eight
everybody happy with those minutes
yep
councillor harding proposes and counts
pellington seconds
and all those in favor
then it goes to full cracks
when would you be planned to take into
court because we've had too many things
that's not gone from pepsi again the
first one was an egm wasn't it so it
wouldn't have been presented there
the next school council is september
yeah
right
public participation we don't have any
public participation tom thank you
and then we go on to page nine which is
the action list
tidy up i think
um recommendations of community and
resources committee that citizens advice
um we were expecting to see a report if
that didn't come out
you can have it
[Music]
um
so that went to full council
and was approved within this
the current budget so that was increased
in line with the recommendation receiver
ons so we did have this discussion about
whether we bring a report back to
external but it's already been to full
council for approval so it's just going
to be a verbal update that that's been
approved
[Music]
um
council pennington letter to be written
to defra that has been done and we are
still awaiting a reply from death row
but i have one from
um
mr cox
nature recovery network with the joint
planning committee policy committee
yeah there was an email circulated to
all of them
[Music]
it was a pity we didn't know before we
had southwest water and the environment
agency they were getting one star
rewarded
one star and they've been classed as the
second west
performing coming out of water companies
in
[Music]
hot weather the last few days
about the
millions and millions of gallons of
water it's in leaks
not just facebook sport but they're all
as bad as one another
you know but they're asking us to save
all the time
millions of gallons of water daily
that's one good thing about this um
we're having is there a heatwave
you can see where the leaks are and
everything the fields are all burnt
except for where the leaks are
um
southwest waters to provide a copy for
presentation
slides i've just done that one
and cheryl says they're still waiting
about the report about progress made of
box meals
and they are doing a special um thing
for the
mortgage companies
so if anybody wants to sell in the area
then they'll cover it saying it will be
done
[Music]
[Music]
shall we leave that on there
[Music]
that's it
sit on the edge nice and short
number five declarations of interest
uh members with interest should refer
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interest when the item is
considered
we only have one item
we may have no items
um agreement at the agenda part one and
two we've only got part one
and this is where
she's definitely annoying
um urgent matters are rising and walk
forward commission of the chair
um for the september session
i'm looking for shirley there she is
um we have that we'd like to see someone
from the dentist provision
we have requested that and they haven't
refused to come
but they're not going to come
because they actually um
present and report to devon county
council direct
so i think we were going to ask are we
going to ask cancer helia to come along
or to report back to us um she sits on
that yeah i think
hello
committee that the report goes to
they've also um
said that they can share the report that
goes to that community with us so we'll
chase that up
they
then it will be a duplication of what
they've um presented to devon county
council so i'm happy if we get a copy of
the report
and stuff yeah i yeah thank you i am i
mean i don't want to waste any of his
time i'm sure
so
as long as we get
the report that goes to dcc that's
that's fine i just want i just want to
know
you know once it's been said about it
and
it plans out for the future because it
is
like intense really desperate situations
[Music]
um
would it be possible if we're going to
have sight of this report
when it's issued to the councillors that
we could feed in questions through
council mahalia if there are any issues
yeah because i think otherwise we're
going to see a report and
if it doesn't address issues
specifically
dentists
yeah that's a good idea yeah
um
yeah well
if that reports
to you any time now is it going to be
discussed
do you know anything we discussed the
my understanding is that they have a
quarterly report that they do further
health overviews
so i think it's a regular report that
they send through to that committee
yeah i mean if we if we can have it
before the september meeting and if
councillor haley can come
because she's on that commitment
um then we
well if it's been discussed by their
clinicians you're not going to tell us
what their committees
the responsibility of the county
councillors to feed the information down
to us as well
if it's not terms of being able to ask
questions no it's not
right and
as i said i think that report will be
probably covering all the debt that was
tourism
let's um get our hands on the report and
um
we'll play it
we'll see what the contents are and then
make a decision from them
well unfortunately
our lady's not here
so um
i'm going to skip that one and we will
go on to consideration of the forward
plan
now i have been approached by
um
a county councillor and
um
some of our colleagues from the eastern
waterside and they would like us to
request the pollyfield community center
come in and
present to us perhaps their future ideas
their forward plan
and
take questions from counsellors
i'm thinking we do have a gap in
september
and that gives them enough time if they
want to come
to come
and
present
um
we can't actually scrutinize them as a
group or as an organisation because they
are a charitable organisation
um but of course they're on tourish
land
and i think we need some clarity of
what's going
i've never been able to find out exactly
what this position is with polyfill
because
it belongs to torres district council
and the site does it there
but it is run as a separate entity
and the football club up there they
don't know
[Music]
no we
just lease it to them we've got no input
or control over what they do and
um how they run i can circulate a copy
of the police to members of that that
helps but we've got no say in anything
that they do it's their tenant of ours
effectively and
[Music]
are you talking about
the whole site
no the building the center
center
right is it the community association
they're called
sure and the building is owned by
porridge
at least
stacey's just going to update us as to
how long releases they're normally
25 years old i'm sure
[Music]
i think that's going to
[Music]
as far as community center or community
or
some of the villages as far back as the
walls they've got they return that
benefit
at least noise
yeah so their lease is until the 7th of
june 2076.
2012
for use as a community center
so yeah a very long lease
like 64 years
i know i did again what way before my
time with freight council friends and i
i i
i i expect you know it's a building
that's from the community so torrid at
least it to the community
um
and it was probably i mean i think
nowadays we certainly don't have those
sorts of length releases because what's
fit for use at the time
isn't necessarily fit a good few years
later and certainly going to 2076 i
can't anticipate another lease that we
would grant for that period but
do we own
the bmx track and all the surrendering
that goes with it
because there was a landscape there
wasn't there and two or three years ago
where they had to repair some of the
lower ground against the paths
yeah
there were a few issues i think that
went through planning as well so yeah
yeah
mr bart would you like to
ask your question again stacy can answer
and yes i was asking the terms of the
need to stipulate what the use of the
community said from the land can be
whether there are regional reviews
and so forth
have a cool event
to see if there's increases but
effectively they are a tenant of hours
so we have no say over anything else
really um i wouldn't imagine we've got
rent increases to a community
organization i mean the rent is a pound
yeah so
yeah thank you
council hawkins and councillor hodgson
is there
only can you elaborate though
why are we going to be asking
is there a particular reason for the
world members
i don't think we've had any contact with
them for a number of years most probably
since 2012.
so it's just to update and find out
what's going on how the committee can we
support support committee you know this
is a two-way conversation here um when
people come in and present it's also an
opportunity for us to see how we can
support them or they might not want any
but you know if they do
they must probably be money
um council hodgson
sorry mine's got a complete blank as to
what others listening to councilman
hawkins the other issue for me is should
we be looking at community laws
um that are owned by toronto at least
two community organizations we have one
in the centre of northern
and to actually show that we've got an
interesting provision
and i know you chair that group i can
update you on that councillor hodgson
declare an interest um i do declare an
interest
whether it would be
equitable or more equitable to be seen
to be looking at more than just one
asset
the other thing is i'm sure within the
lease there are obligations for the
tenant
that um
as well as usage
so
we'll know more than we actually seem to
miss um
if they wish to come in and present to
us we will circulate a copy of the lease
before the meeting
um
being a chair of a torrid owned hall
community space myself
um
[Music]
i'm not really quite sure how to put
this
i've been disappointed
by the support from torridge it's been
rubbish
i can't get anybody there
to look at the roof and torridge are
responsible for the roof i have got
words that they're coming tomorrow but
it's shut because it's a polling booth
yeah it's
your support would be appreciated
yeah it has been quite difficult um
to get information but then we have got
a new estates manager just to come in
place so
um
i've obviously allowed time for that
for the gentleman to settle in
no no
i'll just sure just a suggestion to your
ability to consider
how many other homes
are there any others
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know if we're looking at um
scrutinizing um the organization or
you're looking for updates from the
organization but if it's leases and
properties that would be down to cnr at
the cnr committee
with organizations such as
pollyfield
you can ask them to come and give you an
update on what they're doing but they
are tenant of hours so they're under no
obligation provided they're complaining
of the terms of the lease to report back
to it to us at all um so but i'm not
quite clear on what we're asking in
terms of the it can actually be another
change
so it might an update on what they're
doing what their plans are how they're
getting on
i don't see that we can
it's not in their lease i know on the
northern uh community association lease
all we have to do is paint the inside
walls every four years
and decorate and keep it tidy which we
would do
if the roof wasn't leaking
um
but there's nothing else in there it
doesn't say that we have we pay our rent
i think
and that's it nobody
there's nothing else in the lease
to say we can or can't do
councillor langford um thank you i'm
sorry i mean
i i didn't know exactly what councilman
was asking but
um uh
is there an agenda
is that what he was asking i mean is
there a reason why
this has come up
as to why this councillor inch as our
county councillor um telephoned me to
ask if we could put it on our forward
plan
to ask them to come in
not to scrutinize them as a committee
but to have an update
from them because we haven't spoken to
them for such a long time to see
how's it going what's going on and take
questions from councillors
because
some of the councillors in eastwater
have questions
and aren't getting answers to those
questions in any other form
i think running the
fields
ex leader of this council i think
i suppose one should never i think there
has been complaints
but it's the only um
licensed branches operation
and that's i've got a funny feeling that
they don't run the bar themselves they
lease that to someone else
that may take profits
these are all questions we don't know
the answer to
i mean that's the council we and then
this has been raising the council we
don't have any right to know any of
those um answers
um
i think that you know we can
deal with them
as long as they're complying with their
obligations at least we have no other
um control
they they're
under no obligation to answer a
counselor if they ask questions
i don't know if that is being done that
is just what somebody has reported to me
and again it would be an opportunity to
ask for clarification on that
and again they're under no
liability to answer us
it's just an invite
they might not come
so we're happy to put them in for
september
do you have a gap
is
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing i was thinking said was
and that's
we've got one that's fixed we can't move
the october joint meetings
[Music]
feeling we did
don't worry don't work now
yeah so
the next gap would be 15 o'clock because
you've got um
yeah we could do
are we not with the court reform of
course here should we ask you what other
issues
and then
put in what we believe to be the most
important issue because i think there
are more burning issues than the
political center and we have adopted the
policy and we're doing one all night in
a meeting and we've only got two
meetings left at the end you have to
fill up for this cycle
i personally would like to see something
involving the world devon exeter and not
that healthcare trust to merged together
on the first of april i would like
somebody to come along and explain how
that work is going because healthcare is
a fundamental situation and i would also
like the southwest ambulance trust to be
involved in the meeting
to give some information because that's
far more important and that's our wrong
life here to bring news in and i would
like that to be considered before we
bring somebody in
about the other
[Music]
will do is issues the world members to i
will contact them and ask
a direct question as to why they want
bodybuilding
and see what their complaints or what
complaints they've received
so we'll hold on to that one at the
moment
um we will roll on the link to see if
they can make it next month or september
it's not next month visit
and then can we contact someone from our
dne in northern district
[Music]
it's only july
yeah um but we're looking specifically
how the merge is working between the two
hospitals and i know there's the atm
that takes place in september last year
in marshall but i suspect that i can't
find anything on the website about where
the agm will now take place and whether
we will have to travel to exeter to get
answers to what's happening in our north
devon district hospital and what i want
us to do is what i like our productivity
is to make sure we're you know local
services external services to us
uh how we are
working with them and making sure that
we're meeting the needs of our our
clients because it's going to be six
months down the line there is a whole
few ambulances would be the end of the
summer we've got increased tourism
coming down when the services are being
stretched and i think there'll be a
whole war list of questions to ask them
and even as the second time they've been
i think specifically from the
merger between the two to hospitals i
think there's going to be some more
questions to be raised from that point
of view
anybody else got any thoughts on that
yeah i agree with the council
you know they've only just merged in
um july and what did you say april first
of all the first of april may june july
that was this the first quarter
what do you want a report on the first
quarter or
well i i would like them to be what the
merger is now taking place
uh we will be more clear at the end of
the summer holiday about how the
services are stretched because i can't
remember what our population goes up by
in july and august but already there is
a huge issue with ambulances just
queuing in all hospitals
there's reports of people taking people
over the district to find
entry into to to accident emergency
and i think there will be questions that
that
we would like you know i'm just
concerned about the timing because even
after the summer holiday the 14th of
september's only two weeks later than
the summer holiday i appreciate so but
[Music]
because we haven't seen them for a long
time and then put the merger a bit the
next gap then is 15th of march would be
one year since
[Music]
okay would you delay if you wish but
i certainly put
a second
call from the north american trust and
second and the service in the light of
issues never happened to your services
above
um yeah apology
i was gonna ask well about first
responders because i've had people
contact me and waiting for an ambulance
and then the case of heart attacks and
things like that they haven't had anyone
sort of hope that there might be a first
responder that could get there but there
hasn't been whether that could be raised
as well so at least if the ambulance
can't get there we still know that
someone in the community my daughter's
one and she's now hardly ever been
put on because uh
um fred kuvin they didn't do it and no
volunteers
[Music]
give them another opportunity to present
southwest ambulance trust we're gonna
have to break our own rules with only
one per meeting because we haven't got
enough meetings
that the bringing policy though with the
limited time we've got yeah
so but that's to the next cycle which
could be today's presentation which
obviously something's happened
um but then you've got southwest
ambulance trust
that needs to come in this if you want
that in september but then we haven't
got another one to march 15th
so you're either have two in the next
session
[Music]
but that's still december
well
i'm sorry
i feel the link center is really
important because you're with the person
that was all the big centers um yeah
yeah
so
either way i'm not unhappy with that
because i think health is a real real
um need for our area
so do you want to in the next
meeting then because we haven't got
enough space
i'm hoping for one on the other i
wouldn't want to see poverty
[Music]
[Music]
and then i looked and then i remembered
shirley was here
[Laughter]
yeah so it didn't come off my because i
just knew that it's not a five-minute
meeting he is putting um adrian avery's
putting regular updates and the man was
built yeah which is quite helpful
but in terms of us asking him questions
we still
[Music]
right so we're going to go for the link
then in september
and let's put down on the forward plan
in our little notes down here to be
invited southwest ambulance trust please
karen yeah
and then again
rd and
and
ddh
well you could put them in march
let's get them pending for march yeah
and can we raise those types of concerns
anyway through the community safety
partnership
is that communities
like the weight transfer
that was it not very nice it is more so
please place the
if they do
can
that i couldn't quite catch what you
were saying
um
they've been on the forward plan for
quite some time um
what purpose
does it serve
when we've got very pressing
health and community issues
[Music]
[Music]
we fund that art gallery so that's
an organization that you're going to
want to call in to scrutinize um
and that there will be our cycle so
because we directly fund them members
are going to want to know what's
happening with that funding so that's a
legitimate one
is it necessary to do it then
is that because of budget settings yeah
yeah
and there's also ttbs they're not even
on our list
sure i thought the barton art gallery
was a five-year agreement and i without
looking it up
i thought we'd read a five-year term of
147 000 a year and that was a fixed
amount of money
and it comes up again in 2027 right that
up i do apologize
um but we've been all the way very hard
it's been a hot potato
um back along
i don't think it's quite a hot potato
just as kirk's production said at the
moment because it it is really
it seems really very well but
culturally today that's why we're
getting them in
right to find out whether they are or
they are
okay we can scrutinize those because we
do have financial input
yeah
it always seems to me and it has for a
while and we do mix i mean
internal scrutiny
and we're scratching along tonight
there's not enough work for two
screenshots
we're all scratching celebrities
[Music]
a fellow counsellor county councillors
asked me to bring it to you to see if we
would put pollyfield on i've asked the
question and i think we've got our
answer
i think that concludes the forward plan
and it is full it is busy um
in my eyes i think
and i know we've got a rule of one
meeting but i believe we could find
enough work to do too for me
not what we're going to do
there are that many external agencies
out there that we'd like to know about
but we haven't got space tomorrow
okay can i just ask doesn't remember
independent is there some way i can find
all the organizations which we find that
we occasionally scrutinize
is there a bigger list out there
thank you
we said that
right
seems good
not much to discuss i think we've done
very well
so there's no part two
so unless there's anything else i will
conclude finish tonight's meeting
and the next meeting is the 14th of
september
can we change it to six o'clock
[Music]
[Music]
so we'll move that to six o'clock where
karen visa